hey everyone this is Alan Saki and the
host of simulation I'd like to give you
an update we are currently conducting
interviews on the road in different
cities around the United States with
diverse leaders and its really cutting
edge of knowledge content and we're
really excited to deliver it to you very
soon we'd be spending a lot of time when
we get back in February putting it all
together for you and hopefully you'll
see a steady stream of continued day to
day today interviews being released
really soon really looking forward to
dropping it for you the only reason
we're able to do things like this is
with the support of awesome people like
you so if you can help contribute to
what we're doing and help bring this
content to more people around the world
and help inspire the next generation of
builders creators thinkers doers we
would love that so join us and thank you
again for all the support and we're
really excited to continue the growth of
this project and building the future
together
much love and we'll see you soon